there's a few things about three things
to my account that I need one of them is
something to look up to another is
something to look forward to and another
is someone to chase first off I want to
thank God because that's who I look up
to to my
family that's who and what I look
forward to to my father who I know he's
up there right now to my mother who's
here tonight to my wife camil and my
kids you are the four people in my life
that I want to make the most proud of me
and two my hero that's who I chase it's
me in 10 years so you see every day
every week every month and every year of
my life my hero is always 10 years away
I'm never going to be my hero I'm not
going to attain that I know I'm not and
that's just fine with me because that
keeps me with somebody to keep on
Chase so to any of us whatever those
things are whatever it is we look up to
whatever it is we look forward to and
whoever it is we're chasing to that I
say Amen to that I say all right all
right all right